une des plus grandes affaires
criminelles de tous les temps la sphère
petit os passionne actuellement
l'opinion
le commissaire n'a su
le juge berry et les experts
puis le docteur paul arrive rue le soir
les explications des enquêteurs le trou
par lequel petit on regardait agoniser
ses victimes
la france qui était rempli de chaux vive
et où se décomposer lantoine et cadart
la chaudière enfin où il brûle à 20h30
corps et peut-être même davantage
[Musique]
il faut croire que le crime garde une
fascination dans le monde entier docteur
petiot fait aujourd'hui autant de bruit
que naguère le fameux landru équeuter
landre à côté de petits os qui selon
l'accusation compte 27 victimes et selon
sa propre comptabilité 63 aux assises
devant le décor des 72 valises volé aux
morts l'avocat général monsieur du pain
l'accusé et son défenseur maître florio
se disputent la tête de celui qui tour à
tour violent ironique amer plaisant ou
méprisant joue avec fureur son rôle de
vedette du crime
pour donner à la faire son vrai jour la
cour s'est déplacé rue demeure jusqu'à
la maison du crime qui pour la première
fois depuis deux ans a ouvert ses portes
petit aux menottes aux mains il refait
le chemin que firent naguère ses
victimes lorsque cherchant une sortie
hors de france
elle ne trouvèrent que l'entrée d'une
tombe
un feu de cheminée fut un jour de mars
44 l'occasion de la macabre découverte
on sait ce qu'on trouve un dans l'hôtel
petit on n'est pas gêné c'est criminel
de classes sont de bonne compagnie
[Musique]
un peuple et il ferait les honneurs de
la fosse où la chaux vive rongeait les
cadavres du judas où il assistait à
l'agonie de ses victimes de la chaudière
où il brûlait l'ordre est petit on est
annonce mais à villeneuve sur yonne où
il fut docteur où il fut maire son
souvenir demeure on se souvient qui est
le plus dans cette maison
le docteur dont beaucoup ont connu la
salle d'attentes et le cabinet
on n'a pas oublié que sa renommée le
conduisit à la mairie où certains
regrettent son urbanité villeneuve sur
yonne et le pain c'est le petit a un
passé dont on ne sait pas tout
d'ailleurs car les petites villes ont
leurs secrets
[Musique]